el médico puede recomendar la diálisis
un procedimiento que elimina los
productos de desecho de la sangre en
caso de que sus riñones no estén
funcionando de forma correcta los
riñones sanos filtran los desechos el
exceso de líquido y los electrolitos
como el sodio y el potasio
de la sangre estos productos de desecho
salen del cuerpo a través de la uretra
en forma de orina cuando usted padece de
enfermedad renal los riñones dejan de
funcionar gradualmente lo que ocasiona
una acumulación de desechos nocivos y
exceso de líquido en su cuerpo aumento
en la presión arterial y problemas en
los huesos o en la sangre
y la diálisis también puede llevarse a
cabo para tratar la insuficiencia renal
aguda la cual ocurre cuando los riñones
dejan de funcionar repentinamente o bien
para eliminar drogas o sustancias
tóxicas de su cuerpo
en un tipo de diálisis llamada
hemodiálisis
el médico utilizará una máquina llamada
dializador
para limpiar la sangre fuera de su
cuerpo
algunas semanas o meses antes de
comenzar la hemodiálisis
el médico preparara un sitio de acceso
vascular en su cuerpo
su médico creará ya sea un injerto
arteriovenoso o una fístula
arteriovenosa para acceder a su torrente
sanguíneo
para empezar el área se adormecerá con
anestesia local para colocar un injerto
arteriovenoso el cirujano hará una
pequeña incisión en su antebrazo e
introducirá un tubo plástico blando
llamado injerto para conectar una
arteria a una vena
para crear una fístula arteriovenosa el
cirujano hará una pequeña incisión en su
piel y conectará una arteria con una
vena para hacer un vaso sanguíneo más
grande llamada fístula
una vez que su sitio de acceso vascular
haya sanado su médico puede empezar la
hemodiálisis para comenzar su enfermera
de diálisis insertará dos agujas en su
fístula ave o injerto
una vez que el circuito esté establecido
su sangre fluirá lentamente fuera de su
cuerpo y a través del realizador dentro
del deslizador su sangre encontrará
fibras para el filtrado y una solución
de limpieza absorbente llamado líquido
de diálisis
las fibras eliminarán los desechos y el
exceso de líquido así como los
electrolitos de la sangre
la sangre limpia saldrá del realizador e
ingresará a su cuerpo a través del tubo
por medio de la segunda aguja de su
sitio de acceso
cuando finaliza su sesión de
hemodiálisis se removerán las agujas y
los tubos y podrá ir a casa
en otro tipo de diálisis llamada
peritoneo las membranas que recubren su
abdomen se utilizan para limpiar la
sangre sin sacarla de su cuerpo
antes de comenzar la diálisis peritoneal
se le realizará una operación para
implantar un tubo flexible llamado
catéter
el cirujano insertará el catéter cerca
del ombligo creando un puerto que
permitirá el ingreso y la salida del
líquido de alicante en su abdomen cada
sesión de diálisis peritoneal se llama
intercambio en primer lugar usted
utilizará su catéter para llenar su
abdomen con líquido deslizante por un
periodo de tiempo determinado por su
médico
a través de la membrana peritoneal los
productos de desecho y el exceso de
líquido se extraen continuamente de la
sangre hacia el líquido de alicante el
líquido de alicante cargado con
materiales de desecho se extrae de su
abdomen para ser depositado en una bolsa
de recolección desechable durante su
intercambio